this week on visual effects artists
react
what we got a cool water Croc scene yeah
it's awesome
we got The Bourne Ultimatum this movie's
getting really old but there's still one
shot that's incredible what no Sam has a
clip today that he showed us we thought
we had it it was a trap oh my God no
holy
we got the new Super Mario Bros movie
coming out and I think it's time we take
a look at that oh what a perfect time to
revisit the old Mario movie you have no
idea how important that movie is to
Modern visual effects
[Music]
we're going right into the boring
ultimate we're going straight into the
borny ultimatum
there's a famous scene here I think we
all remember the shot the jump through
the window
look at him go
pretty rad sweet quick little shot yeah
I really like to see that shot be a
little bit longer but it's a pretty
sweet shot yeah for taking up 0.000
one percent of this film it sure has a
big impact
so how do you think this shot was done
um so I think they had little tiny
buildings in little tiny men
no I'm kidding I'm kidding they had a
stunt man jump across the balcony with
another stunt man behind him on a wire
carrying the camera the stunt man behind
him with the camera was on a dead man so
it's stops him from going through the
window and hitting the wall and the
other guy actually has to go all the way
through that's actually exactly it
that's exactly how they pulled off the
filming of this shot for safety they
didn't actually have real glass there so
the glass window was fully CG but I
think the CG glass is like pretty dang
good like we see the reflection of the
building behind the camera that's what
jumps out to you right but we're also in
a world of invisible effects oh what
else was done to the shot I bet I know
what it is there's no interior to an
apartment like that because that's a set
that they had to film somewhere else so
that whole dress department is probably
like crash pads in there and people are
ready to catch them and everything and
very true exactly there's more than that
though the entire exterior of the
building what no but that would mean
that everything that's cool above the
shot stops stops becoming cool no okay
no no it is so cool you guys are asking
the right question like why would you do
this if you're just going to replace the
exterior facade but it's not that
they're replacing it they're extending
it and it's not CG it's a matte painting
and then that gets tracked in 3D space
in a technique that is called 2.5 D it's
the act of getting like 3D moving stuff
without having to like fully like CG
render it all so basically a big like
flat plane that's moving around that's a
picture right exactly yeah the downside
is that you don't get any sort of
realistic lighting or Shadows or
anything like that but in a lot of cases
this one namely it's really not
necessary to do more than that but
because we're not getting big sweeping
lighting changes it's just the camera is
moving through space a little bit now
the shutters next to the window those
are fully CG the window is obviously
full CG but the building itself is so
close to being the same as the original
shot is just extended and you can
actually go through and with like
Photoshop or painting you can just
create that from scratch to match it as
is and then the motion all just works
but I'll be honest I feel like they
could have probably just done this in
the backyard and got it to look just as
good yeah this
the mere fact that they shot this on
location already gives them so much
reference for what they needed it takes
them most of the way their period Well
it does another thing too it forces the
visual effects to be at least as good as
the elements that are real yes which is
important that's very important you
can't half acid thing you can be like
well let me try it it's like the idiot
or a lady that works or it doesn't you
know
Jason Bourne doesn't just jump into
Windows he also likes to disappear right
in front of your very eyes and we
decided to put the Jason Bourne
disappearing act to the test
against unsuspecting people who had no
idea that we were going to do it there's
a lot of literal moving Parts here do we
blow their minds do they think we
actually disappeared
you can watch it right now on Corridor
digital.com or tomorrow on Corridor crew
so subscribe if you are Jake and Bourne
out
all right guys all right guys
buckling up so I don't know the name of
this movie it's a Chinese movie and
it's insane it's insane oh boy okay this
is great I love it when oh this is okay
oh okay
wow
this water compositing
wow this is rad I love the camera work
it's like the right type of kinetic
camera work this is intense this is like
Bollywood Chinese alligator fighting
yeah this is Revenant with crocodiles
man
it was straight up just out what
sorry Croc it's a Croc not a gator
oh yeah oh the tooth knock I also like
how his whole upper jaw just like shifts
sideways when he gets hit by the rock
it's like his jaw also broke
water no it's hitting him so he's
holding something up that has a bunch of
water it's like a big bag yeah you can
see the mask on it actually just to the
left of his head there wow what a shot
right there they're all really tricky
shots there's a few shots that you're
like okay obviously this is CG but a lot
of them I'm just like was that practical
I mean I feel like they're like in a
bunch of these shots like drag in a big
bag of Weights around in the water still
clearly like the crocodiles are CG but
something's got to be like splashing in
in the water here and there I know they
have some CG splashes but like I mean
body slams a crocodile that Splash that
looks like a real Splash to me I mean
obviously he's splashing okay if you
look carefully a lot of the splashes
from the gator don't actually hit the
water yeah you're right it's like
there's a little bit of local Splash
where he's coming out but all the water
that's being thrown outwards yeah that
should be splashing on the water again
is just kind of like Fading Into nothing
there's no ripple from it yeah and then
the water here that's great yeah you can
see that it's coming out of like a cut
or a slit in like a bag too because you
don't really see the water flowing down
off of its back back that's the thing it
just kind of looks like it's spawning as
it's dropping but it also matches the
real actual water that's flowing down
them so it still works as a shot for me
but still like what a great way to set
up that shock because it sells it so
well that lens flare was like yeah that
had to have been added because it was
over the top of the Gator there's a huge
array of different techniques that you
can do in visual effects you know this
is a great example of just a few of
those things working together really
really well first of all they have an
incredibly High detail crocodile model
like this model is really good the
animation that they're doing with the
model is great secondly someone's really
good at Water simulations
those two things working together with
the third thing which is the onset VFX
supervising the best examples of that
are when the VFX supervisor and the
director and the cinematographer they
all really pow out together to make sure
that each shot works the best for what
they're trying to achieve and I think
here is a great example of that
obviously to tie
the young son grow of all visual effects
compositing and it's all just enough to
make you go all right I'm having fun
watching this obviously not real
crocodile fight because you don't fight
Crocs you die I think you can fight a
gator but I think a Croc might overpower
you dude the thing that scares me about
the Crocs is that they'll just grab onto
you and then just start doing that spin
move that he was doing back on them well
see that's why he beat it because he did
his own move against him yeah yeah we
don't often look at Chinese Cinema but
obviously there's a lot going on here
that's worth taking a look at so if you
have any suggestions for some Chinese
movies we can look at with some insane
visual effects leave a comment down
below we'll check it out and perhaps
look at it next time you want to see a
really wacky clip too I got a wacky clip
oh
it's so clean so clean it feels like
oddly CG yeah I first like the opening
shot there I was like oh yeah this is a
fully CG shot but then the people were
real
[Music]
whoa
oh is she growing up
oh dude
oh man he doesn't need his help anymore
yeah it's that she's growing up no are
they changing actors oh he's getting
like kind of older yeah again kind of
older
foreign
teenager and she likes her dad again or
does she
[Music]
oh wow
wait wow wow that was phenomenal isn't
that crazy and one of the poignant
Japanese commercial for a train I know
right I'm like trains are like so deep
I'm like what the experiences we have on
trains I'll never forget them like Bravo
it's like I'm gonna go ride a train so
you guys were like all right it's very
CG tell me more how do you do a
commercial like this is it a green
screen and motion tracking for sure like
that background 100 CG but it's just the
light coming through the windows is like
worked out to line up with the light
hitting the guy if he's standing in a
window they have light on him and if
he's standing in shade there's no light
on him they must have known where they
were and like planned it accordingly now
the train isn't actually built like a
real train right now it's segmented into
pieces that are like just five six feet
long as opposed to a full train car
length so obviously the people are real
here and the question is how do you film
them in such a way that we have a
unified camera move with all of these
real people the way you do that is with
motion control whether through just like
a dolly that can do the same repeated
move over and over again or a robot arm
which I'm hoping to experiment with soon
subscribe for the robot arm scrub scrub
for robot arms
so the camera like starts with the
actors on either side of the camera and
pulls out to reveal them and I think it
pulls back to a certain point and kind
of stops and then costume change actor
change just over and over and over again
with the same lighting same camera move
and that's when those people are now
just 2D cards in the 3D render and
they're just kind of like tracked in and
continuing to get smaller the reason I
specifically like this on another level
above just like the execution is because
this whole thing is like a trick if
you're a VFX artist it is a trap wait a
minute it is a trap it's not CG is it
all the stuff that you really think of
CG and they're doing the CG tricks to
accomplish they're not and you should
just watch the behind the scenes on this
because no way
you're like oh yes this is the tech
to do that and then they're like oh yeah
watch this slam dunk of a behind the
scenes
oh my no no
totally
wait
wow oh my god dude I was convinced this
was motion control no it's just a
hundred people this is one of those
pieces where it truly takes a very
talented team to put it together the
only way this works is if every single
person involved on it is at like a
hundred percent there's so many little
pieces that could technically go wrong
on it and requires this flawless like
team execution to accomplish there's
more coordination this and the vast
majority of like TV shows and movies
what's that matter exactly what blows me
away is how many people they have
working on this one shot right here all
like on set right now you know all of
those little things sliding back and
forth if this was done on a more modern
movie you know they probably would have
just hooked up all of those little
slides to like pneumatic actuators
hooked up to like a program so that like
they could all go exactly and said they
have one person for every single slide
just pushing it you know what's crazy to
me is that they're like we're gonna do
it for real so we're gonna have this
really long set we're gonna have to make
the train Bend it's like that's great
it's like what about the lighting it's
like oh yeah we need to have our shadows
go across all the actors the fact that
these tracks that are running these
Shadows all the way down the set like
what a commitment to like getting the
shot this is a banger Sam
yeah I'm kidding you know this is the
coolest thing I've seen all day yeah I'm
not gonna well I gotta give some credit
I was sent a message by a viewer with
this commercial and it was so
mind-blowing that I had to share it so
yeah thanks Nick
it worked so you guys know there's a big
movie dropping right
worldwide phenomenon yes
I'm so excited I can't wait to see so I
managed to uh to find a copy of the
movie no how do you wait you got it
early yeah I heard about this yeah we're
under like a few ndas I think
yeah I figured we'd take a look at it
and do some reacts to the effects
okay but it's all effects
so here we are there's Mario and Luigi
I don't know wait is this mid journey
is this is this wait did somebody do a
mid journey early 90s version of the
Mario movie you guys see what you're
doing wait 1980s Dark Fantasy Mario
Brothers movie photorealistic uh
starring Bob Hoskins and John Louise
Louisiana and John Louisiana
yeah so this is obviously the original
Super Mario Bros movie that came out in
the early 90s 1993.
whoa wait hold up I don't know why but
part of me assumed there wasn't any like
visual effects in this original movie so
this movie actually I got a lot of facts
to blow your mind about this movie this
movie is nuts what like what was going
on with this movie
oh yeah let's go man heck yeah wait wait
oh yeah brother
wait how are they spinning that dude is
he on wires is he just have you seen
lawnmower man I think it was a very
similar thing all right this movie is
insanity and looks nothing like the
Mario Universe whatsoever Koopa Square
the set design is insanity there's
obviously a lot of effort that went into
the set design you're right you know
like there's a weird this is a weird
point in time like of 1990 to 1994
there's like judged red and Demolition
Man and Super Mario like this set is
like almost the same set in all these
films it's like gritty street cyberpunk
vibes oh man imagine if they made the
Super Mario World at Universal Studios
like this
and like a bunch of like Street punks
walking around with wacky goggles
and you're like you're like this this is
what you've been working on
wow very strange this like particular
1.0 wait that I mean that's actually
like yeah this is actually kind of well
done it's actually extremely impressive
for the time the tech and we'll get into
that we'll explain why because the gun
was evaporating in front of him so the
gun had to be added and then all the
particles are inheriting the color of
having the image all that on there too
it's not overly hard to do today but I
can't imagine trying to do that 30 years
ago I'm gonna make a monkey out of you
plumber
and there's the mushroom making things
bigger it's very forced into the story
whoa
oh
look at that oh okay nice that was
pretty cool that was kind of cool wait
did who who did the effects for this was
it ilm no so there's a crazy story to
all the VFX in this okay so get this so
only ilm has access to be able to scan
film into computers nobody else can do
this if you want to do visual effects
got to do it the old-fashioned way and
so they're like look Kodak I know you've
been working on something for a while
let's do it and kodak's fine you guys
could be the very first film to use the
Kodak cineon scanner so this is the very
first film to be scanned using kodak's
cineon scanner which is like the
industry standard and they're like okay
cool we can digitize these now what do
we do what tools are out there and
somebody's like excuse me I've been
working on this thing called Flame it's
not done yet and this is the very first
movie to use flame which is like one of
the original compositing programs so
they started working on it and they're
like huh this is weird the shots don't
look right they look very flat and
washed out and they're like wait this is
logarithmic footage we need to invent
something that can change it into your 8
bit linear let's call it a lookup table
so you're literally looking at the birth
of full industry of like visual effects
kind of with this film with digital
visual effects like ilm's doing their
own thing with their own tools but
they're all doing it in-house yeah no
one else is getting to touch those tools
and then these guys are like well let's
start making some tools for everybody
and then you're starting to see that
stuff come out here all the particles
you saw is basically somebody like hand
coding all of those like some really
talented person they brought in I think
his name is Kevin
um and they had these Cool Tools like
you could paint like a paint stroke in
like the particles would follow us
that's how you'd animate is you just you
paint a line and how you painted it and
the speed you painted it would like be
how I did notice there was one where it
was like kind of swirling a little bit
so it's probably just some dude with the
or this Kevin guy just with a pencil
going like
yeah that's amazing to think about how
this movie is actually it is the
foundation of modern visual effects yeah
this film paved the way for people like
ourselves and every other film out there
today yeah I did not expect to learn
that today yeah this is like a
groundbreaking it was actually nominated
for an Academy Award for visual effects
and it lost to Jurassic Park
all right so I feel like having now
watched all of the original Mario's
movie stuff I think we just we got to do
it right we gotta look at the trailer
for the new Mario the new Mario movie
isn't out yet it probably will be by the
time you're watching this but we haven't
seen the full movie yet and I'm very
excited for it
[Music]
foreign
Louisiana
I don't know how to pronounce his name
this feels like I'm watching like a
cinematic from one of the Mario games
blur Studio cinematic remastered Mario
64.
this movie like the aesthetic of it yeah
I love the characters are true to form
they're like slightly exaggerated
versions of their video game
counterparts but they're able to nail
that sort of like full CG Vibe you know
the thing that I feel like they're doing
really well is they're making Mario and
all these characters look like the
renders that you saw on like in print
and advertisement yeah you know
basically yeah it's like when you see
like Mario the beginning of Mario Kart 8
and it's like the nice fully rendered
Mario it's like yeah this looks like
that and like Nintendo's had that style
dialed in since Super Mario 64.
illumination took that look and just
elevated it a little bit but it feels
like you're looking at that it's kind of
nice to not have somebody feel like they
need to reinvent this stuff it's like oh
this beloved franchise let me put a
little twist on it let me put my little
twist on it because you know that way we
can access bigger audiences it's like no
stop it
just go make Mario or whatever it is
you're doing I think you nailed it on
the head it's like they were just trying
to do the cover art that we've been
watching for decades at this point it
has a way of staying true to what you
expect it to look like while still
surpassing my expectations on how good
it can look but that hair simulation on
this mustache
I feel like I can touch it so do you
think this Mario movie can succeed where
the original Mario movie failed honestly
this is probably going to just blow the
first Mario movie out of the water let's
be real this is gonna go gangbusters
yeah kids are gonna love it kids are
gonna be peeing their pants screaming
they'll be going crazy they're gonna
sell so many game boys after this movie
comes out yeah we use we'll be flying
off the shelves
the Wii U
yeah I'm very excited for this movie I
can't wait to watch it so yeah uh so you
can subscribe on YouTube here but if you
subscribe over here on the website it's
kind of cooler plus the episodes are
longer and have way more cool things in
it so you know choose one but you have
to make a choice quick
there's a lot of great visual effects
discussions Happening Here
check it out on the website